coming to a town near you face scanning
for Access oh I saw this and public
transportation it works great as long as
your social credit score is high enough
because you obey fire and then there's
another video I don't know if you saw
Tick Tock where a woman says she's
paying her bills at Whole Foods her
check out with her Palm
what okay it's like a RFID chip for a
bank account you go up to a machine and
you put your credit card in it you then
hold your hand over it and it scans your
hand and then you take your card out and
now your hand print is is connected to
your card
when you're buying your groceries is
that Whole Foods I think it was you walk
up and you just hold your hand over the
thing goes and then you walk right out
no I want this not at all I don't want
any piece of this I recently I moved out
of New York and part of it was like I
don't want this encroaching you know
overtaking of my body and soul and mind
and identity to like go to all of this
stuff we're very close to New York to
having the thing where you put your hand
scanner on just to ride the subway
that's what it says no no